on the hill today for the giants will be
the right-hander logan webb webb 24
years old in the second year at the big
league level six one 215 pounder and
this is what he has done this year in
three starts on one with a 587 era
16 strikeouts against seven walks and 15
in the thirds the one stat that kind of
haunts him is what he does with two
strikes on the hitter
two strike hitters have hit 324 against
him this year so his goal today will be
the kill pitch put those guys away
especially when you have two strikes on
them here's corey dickerson two on two
outs top of the first just getting
started swinging the little bouncer off
the first base side right to belt he's
got it over to first for the out and
webb
gets out of the jam
we'll see
how long he gives the marlins we'll see
he has started plenty in his career 95
starts of the 233 games that he has
pitched in last pitched as a starter in
12 games in 2019 he's got a
career complete game that was way back
in 0-9 with the washington nationals i
don't know if he'll add to that total
today or not
the marlins will bring the infield in
here in the rain and the wet
one and one the count to rough ground
and jazz makes the play flips it to
first what a job by jazz chisholm jr
takes away a hit
as the marlins had him up the middle
and he keeps this game scoreless for the
moment what a play what an amazing play
by jazz ranging up the middle to his
backside and
i think the best part of this play was
he kept
slater at third
my goodness what a play
the giants have runners at first and
third odd dubai will come up bunts it
coming in to score
everybody safe devon laid down a really
nice bunt
just far enough where wallet couldn't
come back to home plate
so flores on the
safety squeeze breaking for the plate
and he scored
wallach who
then almost ran into the pitcher
campbell they both kind of arrived
simultaneously
the ball was out on the grass in front
of the home plate area
and then wallach made the throw and
chism had to go up for it and he
actually
left the bag to go for the ball and then
didn't catch the ball anyway the stellar
to third
and du bond to second one to nothing
giants and here is logan webb swing
there's a shot into the gap right center
field he really crushed it it is on two
bounces to the 415 side can you believe
it liskella scores dubon scores and webb
is all the way to third a stand up
triple
three nothing giants
wow logan webb he got a fastball away
and
he just clobbered it
that is his second career major league
hit his first ever triple
first ever extra bass hit of any kind
and his first rbis
first triple by a giants pitcher since
2013 when tim lincecum did it he's got
four strikeouts and this is bossler the
ball is hammered center field going back
duval still going back onto the warning
track leaps at the wall and he makes the
catch
over his left shoulder that's a terrific
catch
by adam duvall getting his first ever
start in center field today and i said
before he can show any degree of
competency out there he might play out
there some more all right here we go
baseball in the fourth inning garrett
cooper strike three call that one was
on the corner cooper can't complain
about that he got away with on the pitch
before logan webb gets his fourth
strikeout of the game
magnoris sierra
is going to be the pinch hitter for
campbell ground ball to second not hit
that hard backhand in the second for one
dubai defers two a double play
doesn't hit all that hard they still
double up the very fast
magneris sierra
the stella gloved that ball and
immediately made a backhanded flip right
to the back
to dubai who
came across the bag the timing was
exquisite
kicked the bag
and
doubled up sierra
stremski has moved over to third belt
has
broken his bat hitting a ground ball to
third and he is also struck out now the
pitch belt
drives one well to left field going back
dickerson and near the warning track
reaches up and makes the catch
that will get it done yostremski tags up
and he scores
four four-nothing giants real hard hit
liner to left field that forced
dickerson to go back on it now here's
jason vossler the rookie left-handed
batter swinging he hits a fly ball to
right field shallow in and to his left
and not getting there cooper it falls
just in front of him for a base hit and
that is the first major league hit for
jason vossler
in his third at-bat in the big leagues
dickerson at second birdie at first
pitch is grounded softly towards second
lastella charges has it flips the second
one dubon very niftly flips it to first
it's a double play
and logan webb finishes seven with
another ground ball double play
giants defense really helped him out
there
jesus aguilar will back he's uh had a
knack for some late ending home runs
recently be a good time for number three
pitch is hammered left field it is deep
it is high it is far and it's gone
aguilar
third home run of the season
third home run in this series
his third in as many days and it's 4-2
san francisco here in the 8th inning
this is now a 4-2 ball game
the big guy getting it done once again a
no doubter to left
get a fastball from whistler you don't
see too many of them it is
the last three outs of the game that
tyler rogers is being asked to try and
get it's the 14th game that he has been
in this year he's got a save
this is a save opportunity
and he's going to face dickerson who is
one of the better hitters on this miami
club
slowly hit it's going to be a tough play
listella is going to make it and it's
not in time here's roger's and there's a
ball bounce to second they could do it
again the second for one the throw to
first not in time birdie was too quick
for him that time a couple of big
bounces to the stella he made the
backhanded flip to
and
dubon
relay back to first was too late so now
the tying men are on for miami and it's
up to lewis brinson and that one gets
over the head of lustella into right
field birdie scores
leone moves up to second and the marlins
still alive it's four to three so now
it's jazz chisholm junior ground ball to
second
the stella's got it over the first in
time and we all had to sweat it out a
little bit here in the ninth inning at
oracle park
but the giants hang on